Many data science concepts build on
previous work with relational databases.
Companies have been capturing
and analyzing data for decades.
Even today, the relational database management
system is the cornerstone of enterprise data.
You need to understand the DBMS
terms on your data science projects.
One place you'll likely run into them is
when you're focused on data warehouses.
An Enterprise Data Warehouse or EDW is
a special type of relational database
that focuses on analyzing data. Traditional
databases are optimized for online transaction
processing or OLTP. A data warehouse is
used for analytical processing or OLAP.
Think of it this way. The typical database
is focused on working with data in real-time.
A data warehouse is focused on analyzing
what already happened. Imagine you have
a website that sells running shoes. You've
hired an engineer to create your database.
They've created dozens of
different tables and relationships.
There's a table for customer address, a table for
shoes, a table for shipping options and so on.
Your web server would use a SQL statement to
search the data. When a customer buys a shoe,
it would join their shipping address to the shoe
then it would give them their shipping options.
You'd want this database to be fast and
efficient. It's a transactional OLTP database.
It should be optimized so that
when a customer finds their shoe,
joins it to their address and ships it to
their house, you want your database to focus
on speedy returns. Your customer
wants to do this in real-time.
You may ask your database engineer to create
a script that uploads the data each day to
your warehouse. Your data warehouse is
optimized for analytical processing.
It's an OLAP database focused on creating reports.
You might have a data analyst create a report to
see if there's any connection between a customer's
address and the types of shoes they buy. You might
find that people in warmer areas are more
likely to buy brightly colored shoes then
you'd take this information and update the
way your website presents the data. You can
change your website so that customers from warmer
climates see lighter shoes at the top of the page.
Now, say that your website has been very
successful. It was bought by a company
that sells sports clothing. That company
has one warehouse for all their websites.
They want to take the data from your website
and combine it with all their other websites.
The company will do something called
ETL, which stands for extract,
transform and load. They'll pull
the data from all their websites.
Then they'll load the data into their Enterprise
Data Warehouse. The company will extract the data
from your website in a standard format then
they'll transform the data into something that
works well with their data warehouse. Their
warehouse could have a different schema than
yours. The data analyst will spend most their time
scrubbing and joining the data so it will fit.
Finally, they'll load the transform data into the
data warehouse. A typical data science team will
have similar challenges. They'll also very likely
use the same language. One thing you might hear is
we need to ETL the data in the warehouse so we
can move it into the Hadoop cluster. What this
means is that the data analyst need to transform
your data so they can move it into your cluster.
Another area where this may come up is that many
organizations see Hadoop as a replacement for data
warehouses. You see a lot of companies rewriting
their ETLs so they can load data into a Hadoop
cluster then they faze out or shut down their
warehouse. Organizations that are hoping to save
money by storing data on inexpensive hardware.
Data warehouses are usually a costly appliance. In
either case, you'll certainly run into these terms
and concepts as part of your data science team.
Try not to get overwhelmed by the language.
Unfortunately, much of data science
is still about gathering the data.
You'll spend many hours in ETL meetings
before you can ask any interesting questions.
If you understand the terms and challenges then
you're more likely to get the data that you need.